ALL SUMMER.
THAT WAS REALLY THE BEST.
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE SAYS
NOW THERE ARE NO PLANS TO FORCE
AMERICAN TROOPS TO GET THE COVID
VACCINE WHICH IS AN INTERESTING
DEVELOPMENT, SO FAR, THEY’VE
BEEN HESITANT TO RELEASE THE
EXACT NUMBERS OF VACCINATION
RATES FOR TROOPS BUT THEY DID
DISCLOSE OVER A THIRD OF THE
MILITARY WHO WERE OFFERED THE
SHOP REFUSED TO GET IT.
LISTEN.
>> OUR TOP PRIORITY IS TO DEFEND
THIS NATION AND TO PROTECT OUR
INTERESTS.
AND TODAY, THE MOST URGENT
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS
COVID-19.
>> NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER GRIFFIN
HAS ALL THE DETAILS ON THIS
DEVELOPING STORY FROM THE
PENTAGON.
>> MANY SEE THIS AS A MILITARY
READINESS ISSUE, DEFENSE
SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN ENCOURAGE
MORE SERVICE MEMBERS TO ROLL UP
THEIR SLEEVES AND GET THE
VACCINE LIKE HE DID.
>> ARMED WITH THE RIGHT
INFORMATION, ACCURATE
INFORMATION, TROOPS WILL MAKE
GOOD CHOICES.
>> THE CEO OF BLUE STAR FAMILIES
DEDICATED TO HELPING MILITARY
FAMILIES SPOKE TO ME ABOUT THEIR
SURVEY LAST DECEMBER THAT RAISED
EYEBROWS AT THE PENTAGON.
>> WE DID OUR ORIGINAL SURVEY TO
SEE HOW MILITARY FAMILIES WERE
DOING AND FRANKLY, WE WERE
SURPRISED TO FIND THAT THERE
WERE SOME CONCERN THE MAJORITY
OF MILITARY FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SERVICE MEMBERS WERE RELUCTANT
TO GET THE VACCINE AND EVEN
LARGER NUMBERS DIDN’T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE IDEA OF
GIVING IT TO THEIR CHILDREN.
>> CHARLES EGGLESTON SERVE 16
AND A HALF YEARS IN THE ARMY,
THREE AND A HALF AND WALTER REED
AFTER BEING HIT BY A ROADSIDE
BOMB, HE BLEW THE WHISTLE ABOUT
BLACK MOLD AT WALTER REED AND
NOW HAS A NEW MISSION, FIGHTING
VACCINE EVIDENCING HESITANCY AMO
AND VETERANS.
>> IS NOT EVEN APPREHENSION, IT
STUPIDITY BECAUSE IF YOU SEE
PEOPLE DYING AND THEY ARE
BEGGING TO HAVE THIS DEVICE SO
THEY COULD LIVE ANOTHER DAY WE
LIVE ANOTHER YEAR, WHATEVER THE
CASE IS YOU SHOULD BE ON BOARD.
>> OUT THE FIRES ARE SHOT, BUT
HIS MOTHER REBECCA DIED SIX
WEEKS AGO WAITING FOR HERS,
INFECTED BY AN UNVACCINATED
NURSE AT HER RETIREMENT HOME IN
VIRGINIA BEACH.
>> SHE WAS JUST WAITING FOR THEM
TO GIVE HER A SHOT.
AND SHE CONTRACTED IT FROM HER
NURSE WHO WAS A TRANSPORT AND
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEAR,
SHOULD’VE HAD SOME POLICY AND
PROTOCOL THAT I’M SURE THE NURSE
WASN’T FOLLOWING.
IF >> PFIZER GETS FULL FDA
APPROVAL, THEY MIGHT CHANGE
THEIR MIND TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND THEIR UNIT.
>> Gillian: AMAZING STORY,
THANK YOU FOR TRACKING IT, WE
APPRECIATE IT.
IF IT’S INTERESTING TO HEAR THAT
THE MILITARY IS NOT GOING TO
REQUIRE TROOPS OR MILITARY
PERSONNEL TO GET THE SHOT BUT
NOW HEARING SOME AMERICAN
COMPANIES ARE FORCING THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO GET THE SHOT BEFORE
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO COME BACK
INTO THE OFFICE THINKING OF SOME
OF THOSE POLICY DISCREPANCIES
YOU WERE HASHING OUT WITH
DR. SAPHIER.
>> John: A LOT OF TEACHERS
UNION IS DEMANDING THAT THE
STUDENTS BE VACCINATED AS WELL.
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO TAKE A
VACCINE IS ONE THING, FORCING
THEM TO TAKE THE VACCINE GETS
INTO A DIFFERENT REALM OF
THINGS.
I HAPPILY VOLUNTEERED TO TAKE
THE VACCINE, I KNOW YOU HAD
COVID AT ONE POINT SO YOU HAVE A
NATURAL IMMUNITY THAT WILL LAST
FOR SOME TIME.
>> Gillian: HAVE ALSO BEEN
VACCINATED.
29 WEEKS PREGNANT, SO NO
CLINICAL TRIALS, BUT MY DOCTORS
BOTH RECOMMENDED I GET THE
VACCINE SO I DID IT.